welcome back I'm looking at a photo of a
heinie oh very nice I'd like to thank
the person who took it yeah you're
welcome
hanging out with Mark doorman Yvonne
Bennington of course can I say with
these I follow a lot of Instagram [ __ ]
right and they promote each other quite
well like as far as women go they really
support each other do they
yeah most girls are catty and hate each
other these Instagram Lina girls we just
post like their selves and dirty little
bikinis and yeah photos yeah oh yeah
hump day is a favorite of mine oh [ __ ] I
missed hump day it was yesterday
no no it's every day on its death no I
follow uh Chris Hardwick's ex-wife it's
so sweet oh boy did you see the [ __ ]
that now there's the video that they
released of her saying what an amazing
boyfriend you are let me watch it in the
hospital have you seen it no no no I
have not seen the video I read the text
that we talked about yesterday this is
one that was released by it looks like a
Patty Hearst again came out and defended
him and this was a video from when they
were dating he was in the hospital Club
but Patty Hearst also defended the SLA
that's great
do you know you raise a really valid
point as better people can be defending
you yeah yeah she but she is but look at
the left side of her mouth she's been
fishhooked many many times underrated
sex move where did you see the video it
was our it was on Chris Hardwick video
yeah they were to see it he was in our
prep was it yeah you know who defended
him yesterday made a couple good points
was Aziz Ansari Pictures know what
they're getting in for am i right it's
important to have good friends like a
support system you know maybe it wasn't
enough prep I was just look I was
looking just reading about check Twitter
at mentions Travis said he doesn't know
what you're talking about I didn't see
any did you watch your videos yes ok ok
it wasn't it was it look yeah here's the
problem for him
it's all true once they pull you do they
ever put you back I mean with resurface
clout you just had it
buddy yeah right now not one over there
they go
yeah because with with everything that's
been done yeah because know if people
stop do they lose interest as the days
go on right right I remember Friday was
the head they heard right yeah Friday
was when everybody was like yeah Chris
Hardwick rapes right then you go like no
what no let's let's start let's start
unpacking slowly it's actually like Duke
Lacrosse it's still yeah it's still a
punch line but they didn't do it right
same with OJ right Charlie Charlie
Charlie really was a bad influence on
salutely have to go down yeah it was
around it this resurfaced yes she's
telling him how she loves them and what
a great guy he is yeah it just doesn't
stand up he little wallet and abusive
situations editing now yeah that she put
out when they were dating right all
right yeah that a real hair color on
Chris why was he dating Lenny Dykstra's
in the [ __ ] first place baseball fan
screaming at her the [ __ ] are you doing
yeah I don't really go to the resurfaced
could you click on that link original
story there you know in the bottom
wasn't the bottom no there's a link to
the story I'm just yeah okay let's not
get argumentative over there no I can
destroy no I'm just doing the best I can
you see the computers running slow I
would say he's getting his T's in a
bunch but he got a bunch cut off so it's
not as easy anymore is a bad day you
know we haven't always had the best
relationship but she was there the whole
time and she was so sweet and she took
care of me when we put our differences
aside and I feel like we have a much
better relationship now and then of
course I want to thank Chris my amazing
loving sweet boyfriend who be a good man
from him so show without worrying and
then he showed up five minutes after I
told him well I guess but she's not
gonna go on like a YouTube video and be
like yeah and the first question he
asked was when can I have sex with a no
again this is the only the only like a
public thing she also she goes on to
describe how good he was to her points
[Laughter]
[ __ ] anybody else right frame with a gun
yeah you see save my ass so now he told
me it belongs to him yeah but all the
stuff just it just doesn't help what
she's saying when you're showing text
from the actual relationship and you're
showing this I'm not saying the text was
a little more damaging I don't think
this really means anything she's just
saying the guy slept at the foot of her
bed when you're saying the guy you said
that actually abuse a - oh she said yeah
but here's the thing it doesn't matter
he's out right he's already [ __ ]
torpedoed the sub you know I mean like
what the [ __ ] is he supposed to do now
right he's got to wait four years ago by
oh no I don't know if he is I don't know
if he is because this stuff allows
people to look at it and go like stick
around for the conversation yeah they
deal with disease absolutely they do yes
they do that with as easy as ease is
still doing great
because people push back and now that
there's a push back I'm gonna take why
I'm just telling you that he hasn't come
out hazing was the article itself though
he is these thing it wasn't like anybody
presented any other evidence people just
read the article and when there's
nothing to this like even if everything
in the article is true
zees didn't lose his gig if Netflix or
whoever would have cancelled him you
know I mean and that's what this place
did they just [ __ ] into the show and
Ronnie panic but it no Aziz because
there was no woman speaking there was a
push back from a feminist and then the
the two other right the woman kind of
bashed the other woman who spoke back
out and then they they got into it this
helps him on a certain thing because
there's nothing she's pushing back on no
this is why she says this horrible stuff
about him whether it's true or not okay
he really
text messages backing up what he said
and he releases this the text messages
are very helpful but here's the thing -
maybe you guys but a lot of people
offend it that he's like saved these
text messages I'm saying women right
right where the thing it's not [ __ ]
played out where this is a front of a
jury
MC [ __ ] kicked quick now could he'd
probably get new shows someday yeah but
he's not gonna get his gigs back wait
women are offended that he saved their
tank well yeah when he said there are
women who already say he's attacking the
victim like the PR point of view yeah
the smart move is to like literally not
do that I don't think but I don't think
he's attacking her other than saying no
no what she's saying is not true and
here's why it's not true he's not saying
she's a piece of [ __ ] you're right but
it's not we're not talking about
logically are they right or wrong words
right logic logic is out baby
no but it's not there's not this actual
conversation happening it's got him
pitchforks are out yeah but Pete on
peace while watching this people who are
not speaking out are still watching this
and while they may not be saying
anything they are reading this and they
are watching what's happening and
they're like oh okay
that makes the least sense according to
its frowned upon though but to defend
yourself here yeah if you in a way he
defended himself well and he was right
to do but also here's the tough thing
for him
he's a host of stuff you know I mean
like he's not diseased has his own
stand-up he could go to but this guy
shows up on a game show
hey everybody welcome you know he's
somebody's got a cosign instable you
know anime oh yeah yeah you know he's
not supposed to be a guy that you're
like hey what's he like well you used to
do Caroline's so you think he can do
that now oh no I think you can go back
and do stuff like that but the kind of
work that he was doing is real
mainstream stuff right you know yeah and
I mean there's a reason why day one it
was like it took up six trending topics
on Twitter and ever since then every
single day a little less a little less
but his response did get people did all
Galka he's responding and people want
like his response is reasonable and if
your response is reasonable people right
I mean that's how I would respond he's
not saying [ __ ] her she's apt
a person she's no I know that he's just
gonna look logically but the well that
that outrage grew doesn't really worry
about the outrage group because the
outrage group is never gonna change what
they think they're not ever gonna come
around go okay because it's not about
the right or wrong of this litigation
don't you think the outrage group is
what pushes networks to make these quick
decisions yeah but they're not the ones
who make the decisions and if you give
the network's a reason to look like you
know okay well this is what was
happening the outraged groups know they
just panicked and and and reacted but if
they have this this gives them a reason
to go well no I mean this their spikes
in seniors to think there's other guys
that can do that job that he does and
one thing you don't want to be is fired
when you're when you're with a network
right you're just like I just want this
thing to breeze through and if it
[ __ ] hits I take credit if it blows
up it has nothing to do with me but if
they suddenly give him another gameshow
job and people start to complain they
look at the guy who [ __ ] made the
move did did they actually fire him or
just put his show on hold like he's even
booted out of the years it has he been
booted from AMC no and I don't know it's
on hold
review I didn't know that Sonny was
fired they just held his show premiere
and NBC said they were doing further
review they're gonna invest in the wall
yeah the wall doesn't come back to us
but they actually said okay we're gonna
you know they actually did the
responsible thing that we're gonna see
what this is hasn't been fired from
anywhere else so no one is fired no I
didn't know that that's good yeah and
it's a weakened but I'm yeah if he can
if he can stay underground until
September
he could easily remember now that Sierra
miser says Chris Hardwick fired from
talk show I don't know if this farce
personally I don't know if that's
accurate alright I think it was placed
under review
I think that was am season III thought
so to believe I'm gonna believe scary
mommy calm ha ha ha
call a doctor it's [ __ ] beautiful god
damn yeah yeah you know her dad was
[ __ ] great player he was back in the
news to see that night Roy yeah what is
he like 60 and you still got [ __ ]
Molly autumn yeah he's enjoying life
yeah [ __ ] uber driver tried to have
[ __ ] kidnap on me said well what
happens they've done that to me a few
times
sure big celebrities use lenny dykstra
drivers try to kidnap hundred percent a
lot of ransom on the line but the body
cam footage I have not seen it I didn't
see this imagine he's a little obnoxious
I know start with the newspeople that's
good he's usually he's usually pretty
level-headed why is the news lady
talking over the [ __ ] video he says
shut up [ __ ] let's see that's what I
have these four I'm pointing my ears not
Lenny Dykstra now Lenny Dykstra an uber
is not a drunk guy thanks but looks like
George got up and walked away from Otto
[Laughter]
he's ready the [ __ ] is wrong right now
[Applause]
his Dijkstra popular something he said
he did and Dykstra said that couldn't
possibly I don't have I don't have a gun
that's that's crazy I wouldn't have done
anything like that
I said I'm gonna look at the bushes and
if I find a [ __ ] gun in there Lenny
yeah no no no no no I and even if there
is one in there it's not mine yeah
there's my princess from a long time
yeah they're getting rid of drunks and
ubers now you hear that what hit me
you're not gonna pick up drugs anymore
well I mean I get that but that's kind
of the attraction of ubers ride that's
all it is you don't have to drunk drive
and it gets paid through the app so it's
not like you're gonna get drunk and not
have money on you or something well
that's right
not just starting fights puking in the
college's play there's private issues oh
yeah I'm a nightmare to drive that
[ __ ] problem is Saturday night I get
late though
uber drivers oh yeah you know these
drunk [ __ ] get in and they big it all
wacky yeah earn a whole bunch of
sexually assaulting as well sure but
it's a give-and-take I see
yeah no I I think that's it doesn't make
any I get the doober doesn't want people
puking in there I guess in their drivers
cars but why why would you have a car
service it doesn't pick up drunk people
I know that's the whole thing exactly
it's to prevent you from killing
somebody yes right I think if they were
smart they'd put a hitch on the back so
they can pull your [ __ ] car home till
yeah exactly
interesting there's a couple bucks I
can't imagine driving around just
[ __ ] picking up strangers though
you're a DD now yeah all night yeah
terrible you know what it's always words
man as I see young people a [ __ ]
they'll get in the front seat next to
the driver that is weird I would never
[ __ ] dream of that you know he used
to do that Patrice it wouldn't be overs
it would be like a car service but
Patrice would always sit in the front
seat
/ - fake humility tryna act like you
didn't think he's a celebrity he would
talk to the guy yeah always
he's changing the radio no I knew a girl
hi Stu sent home with uber all the time
and she said that the drivers if she was
hot and the drivers always invite her
into the front seat I'm like you don't
have to do that Dom's being nice well
they would put the front seat way back
like so that you there's no room if you
put your knees in the front oh yeah all
the time
it would Lisa Anne was saying that she
had real uber problems
for a while like that guy there was an
uber driver that would hang out near
where she lives so that every time she
called for an uber he'd be right there
and then she said at one point she got
in the car with him he drove her to the
airport he was jerking off yes he was
driving her to the airport
really Wow okay she was a fan of her
work thinking she'd like it
right yeah he did not like it she told
me not on the way to the airport who
wants to [ __ ] like watching guys
spill it does she report him I don't I
don't remember so when did she tell you
when you were driving her to the airport
you see you guys follow Peter Fonda on
Twitter I love him yeah yeah somebody
tweeted some funny meme of Henry Fonda
going I'm Henry Fonda my kids are dicks
he was just in he was just in here the
like two weeks ago Peter was on my show
how are you he was everything you want
him to be was [ __ ] like it was 1969
with the open was he talking about
locking up kids at pedophiles go for
this [ __ ] yeah he was uh he tweeted out
about Barron Trump he's very upset
obviously about Trump locking up kids in
cages or whatever the immigrant kids and
so he tweeted out that they should they
should tweet or they should lock Barrett
they should bear arms from his mother's
arms and lock him up in a cage with the
pedophile
so then Melania said she was gonna get
the Secret Service involved the tweet
was we should we should rip Baron
Trump's we should we should rip baron
Trump from his mother's arms and put him
in a cage with pedophiles and see if
mother will stand up against the giant
president Preda oh this police believed
top I'm a vice president president she
is married to 90 million people in the
streets on the same weekend in the
country not sure he's a thing
The Secret Service shows up and they're
like you're not gonna do this are you
mr. Fonda you're 74 years old we had to
help you into a chair came too serious
and he's gonna say no and then they
leave that's it that's it that's the end
of the whole [ __ ] story well
obviously he's not gonna kidnap anybody
I don't think so and I don't even think
he has a cage with a pedophile in it no
no but you can't say we should see their
weird thing like you could say I hope
someone or it would be funny if I mean
those are whatever there's a huge
difference between that and we should
which can be seen as [ __ ] calling
people into action it's weird little
things like that you got to watch when
you tweet about anything I would like to
be in the president's family where I
could just like fine trolls on Twitter
and be like Secret Service you got it
yeah that'd be fun and they follow you
for the rest of your life the Senior
Service does that's my residency oh oh
oh you mean yeah Nixon that Nixon paid
for his own private security mmm do you
not trust the Secret Service or do you
not get it if you don't we should was
the last one it could go back but he
said we should hack this system get the
addresses of the ice agents colleges and
CPC ages and surround their homes in
protest we should find out what schools
our children go to and surround the
schools and protest these agents are
doing this because they want to do it
they like doing this Peter relax Peter
Fonda says ask if the hell on twitter
goddamnit hi but you know the Secret
Service is gonna go over there and
they're gonna go like so is you Jack
Nicholson Dennis and then you had your
own bikes right not that he's a crazy
old man right right there's nothing to
any of ya but it is it is like Nicholson
he doesn't he does he does yeah is he 74
yeah older but do you think that means
that if Secret Service follows you
around for the rest of your life that if
people troll you on Twitter for the rest
of your life you can still send the
Secret Service out to them I think they
kind of go yeah you're done yeah
probably give you like two inches yeah
how old is Peter Fonda he's not 74
because Nicholson's in 80s yeah and you
know that movie was 50 years ago he's 78
78 year old man how old is Nicholson
like 82 81 81 I mean what how how would
he say happy birthday happy birthday to
himself happy birthday jack Wow the man
standing on that's great Jack walked in
here the ariana grande of celebrities
thank you very much really amazing
[ __ ] Pete Davidson's it's remarkable
to me Nicholson was the [ __ ] movie
the last real movie star
you really or he won't do TV he won't do
interview not what about Leonardo
DiCaprio he doesn't do any of that stuff
an actor yes a movie star Nicholson is a
[ __ ] movies Tom Cruise have it on the
set of a few good men
he said even seasoned like people that
crew people and actor who are used to
that when Nicholson is on set like it's
a different thing like you're all aware
Michelson I was in a fight a fight yeah
Mike Mike Tyson fight back in like the
late 90s and there was a hundred [ __ ]
celebrities that were introduced and
when Nicholson came in the whole [ __ ]
place just [ __ ] turned and looked at
him and people real just you could have
heard a [ __ ] Pintrest arena yeah they
were all just [ __ ] stare down I mean
like Eddie Murphy and people like that
it was like just jack is walking in here
so do you think the time of the movie
star is gone there won't be there are no
movie stars there's [ __ ] famous suits
that you can put on you could be [ __ ]
spider-man right but then you make the
next movie and then one gives a [ __ ]
right YouTube stars YouTube stars stars
yes who's the closest to a movie star
now like again Nicholson you're right
I'm gonna say Cruz Tom Hanks yeah Tom
Hanks is too much of a guy next door
though don't you think it's like he
seems accessible yeah no he's not right
scene Nicholson seemed inaccessible
right he seems accessible you like Tom
Cruise Tom Cruise movie star yeah his
problem is you know the Scientology
thing and he'll do interviews he's done
he's done you know he's done Matt Lauer
and he's done a few it didn't go well
but well Matt was being glib that wasn't
he was I was the Tom's fault jumped up
and down on the couch and England didn't
have those moments somebody told me they
said that Jack said to this person who
was at his house I've had the same coke
dealer since 1986 and this was just like
last year [ __ ] making that up you
guys know the person who told me the
story and you know the person I'll tell
you out there who told me that let's see
so you can check on it everyone's like
Oh Ron's lying where's the dog let's
just say he's known for the world of
comedy
but I won't go further than that he
books the show oh yeah all right so you
talked to Kevin Pollak now by the way
Doug wants us to come up with every Jack
Nicholson movie isn't it amazing doing
that podcast Doug loves movies it is the
craziest thing that you could do and
twice you and I've been sitting next to
each other and we look at each other go
what are we doing what does this mean
yeah
what did we spend doing now you were
very good on it though uh you know I
thought I had a couple aces in the hole
with Jeff and Beau you did very very
good in the game Jim I did yeah it was
come on it was a winner breather oh yeah
come on through it yeah it's different
Mike though The Fabulous Baker boys I
wouldn't be able to pull out yeah the
Western I couldn't think of I couldn't
think of [ __ ] men of honors regret
but is that just because we were sitting
on the stage like that would you be able
to that's what it is so those names I
would know but I wouldn't pull them up I
mean I was able to pull up the incident
and the vanishing yeah but I wouldn't I
still had cut his way and Fat City and
my [ __ ] bug-eyed I've never seen him
Fat City those power jet bridges those
okay but you had a boat bridges and
you're like I said that sentence I'm
like no man it's George Clooney and then
after you're like no wasn't bridges in
that I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah he was yeah I
remember every little [ __ ] part he
was in the descendents now yeah and I
could I could have been in there for one
more round but in the moment on stage
yeah in that spot I didn't remember the
name the descendents I don't know how
you pulled it out cuz he well you didn't
pull it out but two scenes in that movie
I know but IRA man just remembers like
because I remember watching that movie
and been like oh what's he doing in here
you know it just seemed like out what's
he just got that little roll huh I can't
name any of his movies the descendents I
didn't like that Clooney Hawaii movie
yeah it was mad about that too because
there was no Hawaiians and a [ __ ]
Hawaii movie that's right Yeah right
furious listen Hawaii estate what the
[ __ ] that I guess like saying there's
nobody from Texas in the movie about
Texas yeah but they're brown Jim yeah
they're also you know and are Hawaiian
people now you're either a state what
are you you're [ __ ] out Hawaii in
your state shut up yeah when you tell
that to the Native Americans and my
[ __ ] home state of Montana
[Laughter]
to think of a place that Indians still
live well I don't know any of these
movies man Wow
yeah I don't know any bull Bridget he's
done nothing but work Chris yeah he was
in Greece oh yeah he wasn't greased
lightning was he in the hell is greased
lightning that was not with Richard
Pryor played Wendell ah the driver
driver driver was doing Wendell what
[ __ ] what are you okey Wendell Willkie
is the president ha ha
Wendell goddamnit critics like driving
based on the song from grace yeah it
seems like it's right he was so here
this is partner Oh Wendell Scott yes
Wendell Scott man I'll tell you if
anybody's looking for obscure names of
characters from 70s movies on today's
show they are sat but how did I forget
the [ __ ] Beau Bridges and that I love
I love our surprise really good as a
serious role for him I can forgive you
for it I'm not understanding gardenia
you know Vincent gardenia he's so good
never grease - yeah remember tonight
that wasn't that the guy that played Rex
Manning and Empire Records yes well when
we start getting more towards the the
late 80s into the 90s I can become quite
a Viking okay Matt Lamas in that so
better bring a gift
yeah that's annoying come on you bring a
gift no money we are dumb I saw it on
your face - you brought it as a portly
gift card and it was mocked like what
the there wasn't money on it but there
wasn't no just swipe the card off the
counter
[Laughter]
Wow someone went in there a big meal and
they're like this is nothing it's like
[ __ ] awesome
yeah you're right we had to bring get to
spend money we get no money yeah all
right Oh is your gym at least you get
breakfast here right you got doughnuts
that night
Andrew and a ride to the airport I'm
assuming you're trying to weasel your
way into a ride to the Palisades yeah I
just hang out at the mall I go up six
hours early you know you're gonna be
careful Nick the Poli got punched in the
face there the other night I heard
feminazi oh yeah yes he did well I heard
the police are involved is that right so
he's gonna press charges he says you
should absolutely help Jim Jeffries
career that's right yeah I went by that
Club and I was in Manchester there the
guy with the promoters for Jim Jeffrey
got punched I really did help my forgot
I'm on Opie and Anthony exactly ma'am
all that you liked the bill burr thing
the Philly thing I know that's all good
[ __ ] it really is it can be bad but even
Ron you like you got World Cup fever
right you watch the World Cup you know
what and less this year than any other
year we I feel like it's less this year
in general I don't understand it is even
the city doesn't seem like you normally
run into people from all kinds of the
bars are all I don't act with people
usually maybe it's because of the time
of day that they run it or the fact that
the USA isn't in it you know I guess
maybe maybe but I like international
sports I like the Olympics do you really
yeah no I like it's us against [ __ ]
Uganda I'm like let's [ __ ] them guys up
right now finally the the the world
feels like a neighborhood when you do
that yeah yeah I don't know we had a
soccer team oh yeah what do we call you
don't the Americans the young Americans
[Laughter]
you are not even sorted you know not
even a little bit don't watch it at all
the cups won the World Cup
it's not fun so bar you get into it have
you been watching it nah hypothetic
you could see where people are having
fun eh telling you're in a diner and the
the entire behind-the-scenes staff is
screaming yeah that's how you know the
world cup is on really right control
usually I dancing in the diner the other
more yeah everybody that works in the
kitchen in New York is from Mexico
everybody yeah and I don't give a [ __ ]
if it's a Chinese restaurant
a diner of five stars they're all
Mexicans yeah Mexico still in it yeah
man they want a big game against was it
know who they beat Mexico I have no clue
they just they beat Germany nobody get
knocked out now no because you're not in
that round yet but this was a major
upset and the Mexicans were very [ __ ]
happy Trump was screaming yeah yeah but
the the thing is there's this guy that
used to be our captain landon donovan
and he's doing a commercial where he
were like hey we do have a team in from
america mexico he's wearing this shirt
everyone's pissed off because we go down
there to play they piss and cups and
[ __ ] throw it at our players respect
that yeah that's a sportsman ship Wow
Jim's like why the cup yeah exactly
yeah Jimmy just sits there with his
mouth open like a little kid no no oh
I'm sorry for a lot of years stupid of
me to point that out no no I just texted
me what do you say ah did you pay me
when I did your podcast I went to
Buffalo Wild Wings with Troy like a week
ago and he woke up was on not one
goddamn person in that place was
watching that scream nobody cared yeah
maybe Buffalo Wild Wings in Times Square
just isn't the spot but yeah nobody
cared
it was also 11 o'clock in the morning so
the time of day thing to do with it and
I think the Royal Rumble was on and
that's where your head was at that time
oh yeah if it wave that's what if that
is what was on that's where my head
would have been yeah
in Russia Burger King had to apologize
for their Russia I was a great at Kent
County part because they decided to yeah
promotional campaign in conjunction with
the World Cup that if any woman got
impregnated by a World Cup player they
would give her a whole bunch of money
and free whoppers for life huh and
Burger King was like you can't you can't
just do that Russian kid [ __ ] animals
so that's collusion
it is collusion you're right run um yeah
but they're joking you know they weren't
really gonna do that were they white
give whoppers out yeah what they
probably weren't until somebody who took
him seriously if anybody could eat more
than one a month I'll give him a [ __ ]
hundred dollars which year but the guy
make that bet five years a card there's
a guy who's like that guy you see Morgan
Spurlock's McDonald's documentary way
back over seven years ago you remember
the guy on it that he met who was eating
Big Macs every single day that's my
cousin well your cousin still has he
still has the record yeah he's gone
through like really tens of thousands of
them
he does like at least five or six a week
yeah and he goes in he has this whole
system he goes in he buys five and he
eats to fresh and then he frees his
three of them one and every and over the
next three days he'll reheat them in the
microwave yes then he walks around the
apartment alone telling himself he's not
at all mentally ill right I know we
don't use the term [ __ ] anymore but
there's something a while since they're
eating Big Macs
yeah the haircut would would would say
mental stability well you mean those
bangs perfect he's a good-looking guy
Nick Bohr hey good for him you know what
his [ __ ] cyst if his system held up
after all of this after all the he's
just one of those guys with an iron
[ __ ] system 30,000 big macs have been
put into his system
thirty thousand you know look at him he
gets the large drink too good he said
but no he saves the [ __ ] like rappers
and he saves the seats so he could prove
it and receive completely psychotic but
it's not just so he can prove it it's
because he's a he's a complete hoarder
this is what our yard yeah but a Warren
Buffett he'd say egg McMuffin everyday
with a large
yes yeah did you see the thing is
depending on what the stock market the
stock market is high he gets it with the
coke if not he gets something smaller
with the water like he's [ __ ] wow
crazy crazy yeah yeah like the exact
changed things in his [ __ ] car so no
I can't believe they even let him drive
is that any different than like athletes
that perform at that level that have
their weird superstitions his breakfast
never cost more than three dollars and
17 cents yeah yeah what's crazy I mean
isn't it like like a football player
that has to wear one pair of socks and
he has to put it on the left foot has to
go on first every game like just show
Steve Jobs was like a you know holistic
vegetarian working well exactly
the government was slowly killing him
though oh that's true that's possible
that is a theory about easy either
that's what happened to him I think it
was you told me you suck what you said
Wow I did not put money on the car yes I
do you wish maybe he'd never bring it I
don't mind the gift ups are it's a fun
show do you feel bad about knocking a
friend who's done your podcast who likes
you enough to put you on his no no you
don't feel we are friends so we can
knock each other but I feel bags he's
not here alright had done it to him
right but you didn't put the money on
the card I don't think so no no what is
he up this early he listens to the show
he's probably working on his podcast
that's why he's successful yeah by
picking out movie stuff and writing what
he does he has to find a new guest for
the next time he's in New York yeah he's
working on by the way dice I'm gonna
promote dice is doing [ __ ] the
Gramercy where we did that that's such a
great [ __ ] grater room yeah Chapelle
all I want to say Dave Chapelle the
process I guess he'll just book
last-minute shows there cuz he should
palette he can do that yeah and just
work on material I open for him once
there
did you yeah it was great did you insult
him no no I
now I love 10 Nicholson movies tweet me
I feel like every time you come on here
you say something that you get all
nervous yeah yeah well the Hells Angels
don't listen right right and you don't
mind you don't mind any any ill-will the
Brendan burns would have towards you
know yeah what if you go over there
you're working together that's true
have you gone over no never I've done
Australia I enjoyed that
yeah a little far for my taste yeah I
kind of went nuts how long did you stay
um probably I went in a few days early
my manager met me there we just hung out
it was two weeks mmm little less than
two weeks no way lessons and did you go
around Australia or just to one city Mel
Melbourne and Sydney and we I did a few
sets in Sydney a TV set that I didn't do
that great on it wasn't good
I heard yeah no yeah I read the reviews
not good boy did the bridge walk sit in
the Opera yeah that's crazy
you told us you did that that's out your
mind yeah why is that crazy it's just so
high I'm on top of a bridge I had a
panic attack at one point you did frozen
yeah by the way I did a Friars Club a
couple nights ago and the you know they
do a big roast every now and then sure
Harvey Weinstein and I could cancel it
obviously and now it's Gloria Allred you
know Harvey Weinstein I was I've been
booked on the Harvey Weinstein roasts 30
times under mine they keep changing the
date and do these until these
allegations happen I wonder if they
suspected these were coming out because
I got booked on the Harvey roasts
probably I forgot about it five
different date changes and then do it
again I guess some jokes for you yeah I
got a couple wants to stay away from the
scandal gloria allred you doing I'm not
doing I just saw there was a big plaque
or marquee why don't she doing it when I
think in like two weeks
okay but it's an all-female lineup oh
that's perfect yes so that'll be funny
one after what Hannibal Buress did to
Bill Cosby if I were hiding what Harvey
Weinstein was hiding I would want to
stay way far away from anybody how many
oriented yeah right yeah he's out all
you need is one roast joke for people to
be like is that yeah did you really yeah
it's gonna be hard for Harvey to come
back now
hearse came out and said some good
things about him though that'll help
isn't it crazy that you see those old
videos like Meryl Streep like you're my
hero
yeah you're a god to me yeah he's like
thank you he he did my show a couple
times and then he got my number was like
texting me and stuff and he's very
[ __ ] seductive like he was like oh
yeah are you guys had him on right yeah
you know before you really [ __ ] sweet
and fun and you know you were like oh
man I would love to be in business with
this guy yeah I just rang out with him
buddy yes you know he new radio guys say
you know hey those guys talk about films
right so he probably went out it made a
little effort just to be pleasant and
also you're talking nice about his
movies forever yeah I mean great movies
amazing movies yes change the game yes
absolutely we were talking about the
World Cup
i hears yourself the dog he's a great
guy I'm actually more than I can in the
finish that you took all these vicious
shots at done all right well you gonna
say you know all right I don't know if
you heard what the whole thing that
started when I was laughing cuz you said
what did he say did you hear what he
said what you guys were talking and you
were somebody said this and Ron you
might have said this is like Doug loves
movies and what Mark said was only
better because Doug's not here oh well
that's an easy joke Mark said that yeah
which I don't agree with I feel worse
than Harvey why so wait what about
Harvey now yeah no I don't remember
we're just because we're talking about
Doug oh yeah happy Doug's down here I
like I just needed a line right yeah no
I like doing dog show with great shoes
is that personal I pay him right well
you you because you're complaining about
the gifts yeah yeah right saying it was
a waste of your time and money that was
a waste of time I wouldn't do it it's it
really is a creative pie-eyed me with
the first because when you look at the
fact that it's a simple idea this guy
likes movies and he's made like it's a
live audience experience it with the
[ __ ] they bring the sign it's like a
real thing they love what the audience
loves them and what's amazing about the
audience is it's not like a Doug Benson
comedy audience that is a movie fan on
yeah like they're there for the movie
but I think that they would go to a
stand-up show they probably would but
they're not like there because like oh I
love stand-ups and I just go to these
shows the majority love movies and in
light of mine I think I thought they
were a little disappointed when we
walked out because there was no movie
star there I think that ways one at
least one movie star on the panel well
that's the thing for and that's got to
be Doug's thing like when you first time
you book a movie star it's very very
exciting but going forward you are good
luck you gotta top it yeah exactly
exactly who is he had on what movie
stars I did it once with the director of
exactly he's big Oh No Woody Allen
what's the name of that movie with the
Chinatown you did with Roman Polanski
the driver I'm blanking today I'm having
a real brain movie about Brian they're
the hot guy and Wow wise guys all comedy
club in Utah you did it with Ryan
Gosling in Goodfellas Marty Scorsese you
did one's the good ones good guys the
good guys nice guys yeah that's work
that's that was the movie about Hitler's
final days in the bunker right black
bring a box set of some kind well I know
Edgar Wright's done it should be the one
[ __ ] crazy about girl right what a
woman is I would definitely try to sit
next to him yeah yeah you wrestle first
like kind of just slow down and see
which one he's leaning towards I'd be
like hey no zombies here um who else has
done it Justin Long has done it yeah
yeah I did with him once here actually
Wow
you've done it a whole bunch of times
you just try to have to attack the job -
I just am a big fan right everybody
likes a little money on the side right
sure yeah getting paid for your work huh
you know I do a lot of pro bono [ __ ]
exposure
yeah feeling bad about this
why would you just use you insulting a
friend who hurt us yeah he was listening
live boys he's dug listens to the show
yeah he's been going through a lot
lately so yeah whatever he'd be a great
host for @midnight yeah just putting
that out in the are you saying because
he treats women the way Chris Hardwick
does what the hell does that mean I
stole his Duggars you think it'd be a
good host oh yeah are you kidding he's a
great host of Doug loves movies but I
mean that's a different show and getting
high with Doug could even Doug with ha I
don't even know the name of the show me
I did it
I wanted to relapse on that show you did
yes I'm like bring me on I'll [ __ ]
throw 31 years down the toilet I think
it's a good idea yep bomber I'd be he
hooks it up though I get you an uber you
get baked out of your mind any Hooper's
your home does you do that for Doug
loves movies no Oberer we're just a gift
on you uh-huh
yeah yeah you didn't even pay for the
gift yeah you know there's no money on
the car you could put money on it so
that you save them the trouble of having
to find a new card here here yeah there
there yeah now you're starting a whole
conversation ray in Florida who wants to
comment on what more mark Norman brought
up what's up - uh ray uh well as far as
I know it costs money to get into a Doug
loves movies live event
I don't David let's not even go well
that's your your point right yes yes I'm
the chip chip person podcast live events
so you're not paying him I am oh so
marks probably gonna want to do your
show ya know a little something not a
lot but there's a bigger rooms bigger
rooms what do you think he he rents that
theater for it's gonna set you back
that's a good point does he rent the
theater though you know what that's a
good point
they don't really sell a lot of booze
they're not no more open up and they
were haven't they're having trouble
selling snow cones
it's pretty very expensive I saw a guy
with a balloon say what's that on
Wednesday it's kind of expensive you
don't think what do you think it says I
honestly I have no compare I don't know
what you'd like a Braille if you told me
there's $5.00 I'm again Rain Man I owe
3,000 I go I have no idea you're not a
show business guy well I'm not saying
that
that should be saying that I slept on
the phone with his accountant god I
don't understand how I could pay for
this no I can't can't so I got my five
friends here with me I'm not gonna let
them down so it's expensive
I don't know it's saying all that 650
standing seeded now it's a few hundred
three hundred men be seated mm-hmm good
room yeah it's a great really I love it
check out Doug loves movies on iTunes
follow dog on Twitter to learn about new
dates get mad yeah I like the guy
apparently I know you do have a weird
way of showing it ah yeah would you calm
a welching sleazebag